Kobe Bryant's helicopter crashed and
disintegrated on this hillside in
Calabasas outside Los Angeles witnesses
said there was heavy fog and poor
visibility in the area at the time of
the accident resident Paula Dolan heard
multiple explosions before the
helicopter went down I heard one bang
when it was in the air and then a second
air second bang as it was descending and
then I heard a huge crash on board with
a 41 year old retired superstar and his
13 year old daughter Gianna as well as
seven others including the pilot police
have not released their names there are
wide speculation and who the identities
are however it is being entirely
inappropriate right now to identify
anyone by name until the coroner has
made the identification through their
very deliberative profits and they've
made made notifications to the next of
kin the cause of the crash is unknown
the helicopter sikorsky 76 B has a
robust safety record federal crash
investigators will search the wreckage
and more our team will be looking at the
history of the pilot and whatever crew
was on board we'll be looking at
maintenance records of the helicopter
Brian's prowess thrilled fans in LA and
beyond for two decades a crowd has
gathered here below the crash site
many people are wearing Lakers colors
purple and gold some people say it's as
if a piece of their lives have been
ripped apart he meant more than you
could imagine and you could put it in
words just the passion
and the grit in the sweat and blood that
he's given to Los Angeles for the
basketball family is I can say beyond
words he was an idol everyone loved him
it lays very sad right now he is just he
was he was a great player that's the
reason why I got into a school because
of him that's why I have his jersey it's
still like unbelievable for me to say
that Kobe Bryant is not here with us
anymore
it's just tragedy it's just um it I have
no words honestly president Donald Trump
tweeted Bryant was one of the truly
great basketball players of all time the
loss of his beautiful daughter Gianna
makes this moment even more devastating
President Barack Obama an avid
basketball fan said Kobe was a legend on
the court and was just getting started
in what would have been just as
meaningful a second act amid an
outpouring of sorrow from players from
across the spectrum of sports players
from the Houston Rockets and Denver
Nuggets held a moment of silence before
their game on Sunday players looked down
shaking their heads he leaves behind a
sport that is grieving a city in
mourning and a legacy of greatness that
will be remembered as long as basketball
is played rob reynolds al jazeera
Calabasas California